so here's the secrets they give you 5 11
29 dot r dot three terms that's enough
they're even generous enough to give you
a definition for the general term the
nth term so they tell you this which on
closer inspection is actually fairly
obvious okay so then they ask your pair
of questions part 1 fourth term ok
that's pretty pedestrian they define for
you the end of term so you just have to
put excuse me you just have to put n
equals boring so let's just quickly do
that so 10 4 is equal to on 3 the power
of 4 which is 81 plus 2 which is 83 no
problem then when you get to part two
they're just throw your right in the
deep end what they want is this
expression okay now the reason why you
might and this is the kind of question
which you want to go after okay you
might raise an eyebrow this is because
this sequence well is it an AP it sure
is not because the guy from here to here
is plus 6 and then the gap to the next
one is plus 18 right not a peep is it a
GP no it's not because turn to on term
are one is that and turn three on turn 2
is that him all three numbers are prime
so I'll tell you what I don't even need
to try simplifying just go home okay not
a GP okay not n'ap not a GP and that's
what makes you scratch your head okay
however however doesn't mean it can't
work with it and they're enormous clues
in the question right so the torture
this and therefore i know that this
secret is very very close to a sequence
that if i take every time and subtract
two well i'm going to get three and then
nine and then 27 okay now how did I do
to subtract two and the answer is
because the term said plus two right now
if i subtract
to i get to this thing and what's that
nice and JP like that'sthat's like a
textbook JP okay so here's a GP right
and the difference between this and this
is another GP that's a GP isn't it right
to 22 also happens to be an AP they're
both pretty boring but that doesn't
matter now that I know that that series
is made up of these series it's pretty
easy from there isn't it watch if I want
to get the sum to the nth term of this
this is just the GP right so all I need
is the first term which is 33 should I
choose R to the N minus 1 or 1 minus out
of the end rd n minus 1 okay r is also 3
to the N minus 1 divided by what three
take away one now pause I will evaluate
that in a second but all that's going to
cover is this that's just going to cover
this okay I also need to include this
this gets added all the time as well ok
now it's a GP I could reach my GP
formula it's an AP I could reach for my
AP for milk so you don't really need do
that do you that's together they are the
sum of the first n terms where all of
the terms are two is just going to be 2m
right like if I have 10 terms then the
Sun is 20 that's it i'm going to
simplify let's see so this is 3 on 2
plus it again but they go ok now what
was strange about it what we're strange
is that it didn't immediately fit into
our categories key word being
immediately it didn't take much twisting
and turning and in fact they gave you
the clues that you need it see what i
mean by the questions when it's like
once you see the solution hi have the
pieces all along right but you just need
to push on it until it gives way and
then it just
helps out new lab okay I separated this
sequence which is neither a team or GP
adding to two parts both which are yet
which I can then deal with with my
photos of course yeah absolutely like I
could take this guy and I could add it
to this guy there we go to thank right
so the resulting series would be 4 1130
189 but I've ever got what's that that's
nothing right but if I break it apart is
two very structured things that are easy
to deal with this one well you see they
didn't expect you to figure it out
that's why they gave you the answer that
makes sense they are making the question
accessible but it's still like it
doesn't just hand you the answer you
still have to like look at it a bit
sideways